sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas la situación en la
frontera entre belarús y polonia se está
haciendo cada vez más tensa y amenaza
con convertirse en una verdadera crisis
humanitaria es que miles de emigrantes
han llegado hasta ahí provenientes
principalmente de áfrica medio oriente o
incluso afganistán con la intención de
cruzar hacia el territorio de la unión
europea motivo por el cual el bloque
comunitario ha emitido nuevas sanciones
contra el gobierno de minsk al que acusa
de orquestar lo que califica como un
ataque híbrido entre tanto los migrantes
se enfrentan a las condiciones extremas
del frío además de ser víctimas del uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de las
autoridades de ambas naciones el
siguiente es un reportaje de cuba-
kaminski oliver crac alix bulldog y
comunicación
en polonia cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa un grupo de sirios consiguió
salir de la zona restringida
unos voluntarios polacos les brindan
ayuda cómo se sienten tengo demasiado
frío tienes frío tienes comida o agua no
hay seis adultos y un niño estos
colchones los necesitan dicen que han
sido rechazados varias veces por los
guardias fronterizos de polonia
intentamos volver a nuestro país porque
ya sabes no podemos cruzar la frontera
pero cuando intentamos volver a ming el
ejército bielorruso nos atrapó y algunos
fuimos golpeados puede contarnos un poco
más sobre lo que ocurrió donde lo
atraparon que hicieron en el lado polaco
vale he intentado cruzar la frontera
nueve veces
también un coche
este grupo no quiere ser visto que otro
toma sus datos por si acaso
si la policía nos atrapa te llamamos así
puede llamar nunca pero aunque los
voluntarios pueden ayudar con asistencia
jurídica y alimentos no pueden ofrecer
mucha esperanza
le seré sincero tenemos muchos grupos
que son rechazados así que estos sirios
no van a pedir asilo sino a probar
suerte en el bosque adiós de vuelta a
varsovia y otro confiesa su
desesperación por ver las autoridades
polacas devolver a todos estos migrantes
al bosque helado
quieren que la gente muera para
desanimar a los demás y esto no sólo es
ilegal sino que también es inhumano no
debería ocurrir en europa y
especialmente en polonia
pero no muy lejos de la frontera en
sokolka muchos residentes apoyan la
línea dura del gobierno ven a los
migrantes como una amenaza nos van a
matar ya han robado un coche allí cuando
hoy el
pueblo cerca de la frontera si les
dejamos entrar vendrán cientos de miles
más si polonia lo hace la ola no solo se
extenderá al país sino a toda la unión
europea ya vimos lo que pasó en 2015
mientras tanto es imposible saber
cuántos migrantes se esconden en estos
bosques o cuántos han muerto
en francia la inflación está aumentando
al igual que el costo de las materias
primas productos como el trigo la leche
o incluso los aceites de cocina han
alcanzado precios máximos equivalentes a
los de hace una década lo que es una muy
buena noticia para los agricultores se
convierte en una verdadera dificultad
para muchos consumidores que sienten la
presión aumentar sobre sus bolsillos el
siguiente es un reportaje de catering
bien joan van hoff y denis sebastián
el precio de los productos alimenticios
básicos se está disparando en el último
año el trigo para hacer el pan ha subido
un 37.5 por ciento hay varias razones
que impulsan esta inflación las más
importantes las malas cosechas mundiales
que siguen haciendo subir los precios
para llegar a marta la inflación tiene
un lado positivo para un agricultor de
cereales siempre es una buena noticia
poder vender nuestras cosechas a muy
buen precio marta vio aumentar sus
ingresos en un 20 por ciento en
comparación con el año anterior pero
también tuvo que tener en cuenta el
aumento de los costos del combustible
en mi opinión el aumento de granos no
cubrirá el aumento de costos que
tendremos los patrones climáticos
cambiantes también están afectando a los
agricultores y sus cultivos gracias a un
verano frío y lluvioso la cosecha de
lentejas en francia es la mitad de la de
hace un año esta empresa trabaja con
varios cientos de productores y se
enfrenta a una escasez de lentejas el
presidente dice que no tiene más remedio
que subir los precios el precio de las
lentejas verdes se ha duplicado no
tenemos opción tenemos que transmitirlo
simplemente porque nuestros márgenes son
demasiado bajos y los distribuidores ni
los fabricantes pueden absorber los
costos adicionales y estos costos
crecientes se trasladarán a los
consumidores el próximo mes espera que
el precio promedio de un carrito de
compras de comestibles aumente en un 5%
sudán sigue sin encontrar una salida al
golpe militar que lidera el general
abdelfatah al burhan desde entonces los
movimientos ciudadanos que exigen un
retorno de los civiles al poder se han
hecho más frecuentes pero también se han
hecho más violentos desde la toma del
control por parte de los castrenses ya
se cuentan más de 20 muertes nuestros
enviados especiales a sudán visitaron
tooting una pequeña isla en pleno
corazón de jartúm la capital este
pequeño territorio rodeado por las aguas
del nilo produce la mayor cantidad de
frutas y verduras que se consumen en esa
ciudad y nuestros reporteros fueron al
encuentro de los residentes para obtener
sus opiniones sobre el golpe militar
en jartúm donde se encuentra el nilo
azul y el lindo blanco se encuentra la
isla de tuti y estas tierras agrícolas
ali nació ahí y ha estado trabajando la
tierra durante décadas tuti está en el
corazón de jartúm la crisis económica
que afecta al país también ha
repercutido a los agricultores para
justificar el golpe de estado el
ejército acusó al gobierno de abdalá
hancock de ser la causa de todos los
males de producción es un régimen
militar no puede triunfar en sudán el
pueblo sudanés es un pueblo de
resistencia
abdalá hand ok no tuvo tiempo de llevar
a cabo sus reformas y no tuvimos tiempo
de juzgarlo por sus resultados
en la parcela vecina las mujeres están
ocupadas cosechando ensalada viene de
darfur como este joven que llegó a tutti
en 2019 después de la revolución
la situación actual es muy complicada el
pueblo sudanés se manifestará en mi caso
iré a protestar
en tout y están acostumbrados a pelear
bajo el mando de omar al bashir los
habitantes impidieron que el gobierno se
apoderará de sus tierras para construir
hoteles de lujo pero hoy la pérdida de
esperanza ha llegado a la mente de
algunas personas si hay un nuevo acuerdo
entre civiles y soldados será aún más
frágil que la anterior debido a que los
civiles perderán la confianza de la
calle los militares ya la han perdido
esta unión entre civiles y militares fue
negativa se olvidar de la gente nada más
es una activista muy involucrada en el
movimiento de protesta convencida de la
capacidad de los civiles para tomar las
riendas de su destino
no dejaremos de salir a las calles no
detendremos las protestas la última
revolución le dio esperanza a la gente
sacamos al mayor dictador en cuatro
meses
a los habitantes de tuti y jartúm les
gusta venir y sentarse en estas sillas
multicolores y sumergir los pies en el
nilo para relajarse detrás de este
aparente descuido el sol se opone sobre
las incertidumbres de una revolución
inconclusa
benin recuperó 26 obras de arte que
habían sido saqueadas por las fuerzas
francesas durante la era colonial en el
año 1892 esto como parte de una
iniciativa del presidente emmanuel
macrón que a través de una ley firmada
el año pasado busca retornar patrimonios
a áfrica un verdadero motivo de
celebración para venir sin embargo esto
representa tan sólo una pequeña fracción
de las más de 5000 obras que este país
africano busca recuperar el siguiente es
un reportaje deluxe largo clovis casal y
julian sobre jay y tele key
primera vez en más de 130 años 26
objetos y obras de arte usurpadas por
francia durante su era colonial
finalmente de vueltas en gesto de
reparación del patrimonio africano una
alegría para los locales
estamos muy felices de lo que está
ocurriendo en nuestro país muy felices
es lo que estábamos buscando la
devolución de nuestras obras de arte y
siempre vimos estas obras en fotos en la
escuela y en internet pero hoy somos muy
afortunados porque las vamos a ver de
verdad
es nuestra cultura es nuestro estamos
sobrecogidos
entre los artículos devueltos hay
estatuas del antiguo reino de dahomey
situado en las actuales fronteras de
venir hasta estas semanas se encontraban
en el museo parisino del quai branly y
su vuelta marca un momento un largo
tiempo esperado para los benineses
la espiritual
las estrellas se han alineado desde hace
tiempo para venir el simbolismo de la
devolución tiene que ver con nuestra
alma y nuestra identidad esta devolución
es testimonio de lo que fuimos el
testimonio de como existimos
anteriormente
los awá existe agua las obras pasarán
dos meses de aclimatación en su nuevo
entorno antes de exhibirse en la
presidencia de benin por tres meses
posteriormente se trasladarán a un museo
actualmente en construcción en abomey de
donde salieron hace ya mucho tiempo
uno de los deportes más populares de
sudáfrica es ahora accesible a cualquier
persona en situación de discapacidad
esto gracias a una silla de ruedas
especial que fue fabricada en francia y
con la cual cualquier ciudadano puede
sentir la adrenalina del parapente y
para probarlo de rim comenzó en el fondo
dura de una ong y quien ya conquistó el
kilimanyaro en silla de ruedas se sumó a
esta aventura este es un reportaje que a
olympique me estefan carstens in a donde
jugó un deporte que atrae cada año a más
aficionados y que ahora es accesible
para discapacitados teir link perdió el
uso de sus piernas a los 19 años pero
nada puede detener a quien conquistó el
kilimanjaro en silla de ruedas su
discapacidad la lleva cada vez más alto
a 8 metros y nos rodeamos de personas
que nos permiten acceder al resto del
mundo es el universo el que se abre para
muchos de nosotros es nuestra actitud la
que determina la altura que alcanzamos
en la vida cualquier persona con
discapacidad puede subir una montaña si
recibe ayuda la misión de su ong es
hacer que todas las actividades
turísticas sean accesibles para los
discapacitados el parapente era un
desafío para quienes no podían aterrizar
de pie pero estas sillas fabricadas en
francia cambiaron la dinámica hay ruedas
muy fuertes que nos permiten aterrizar
en cualquier terreno es como una jaula
que mantiene la cabeza y los hombros a
salvo puedo manipular todo con mis pies
para mantenerte en la posición correcta
si quieres volar por tu cuenta puedes
hacerlo sujetando te alarmes hay fijón
una novedad en sudáfrica donde más del
10% de la población vive en silla de
ruedas
es informal
[Música]
[Risas]
a medida que el turismo se apodera de
ciudad del cabo se encontraron con una
ventaja adicional permitir a los
parapléjicos volar en parapente
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana sigue con más
información en france 24 mil 394
puntocom